this gorilla nems check me out on
bootleg kev as usual stupid
we're rolling we got
gorilla names in the [ __ ]
building bing bong
your life yes
you know what's so crazy bro
is uh my son the last time you were on
my show it was like right at the
beginning of uh
i would say your viral run yeah
so my son saw it he's like yo
you had nems on your shoulder you didn't
tell me and i was like
and i just know you because you're a
great rapper
of the disrespectful sword yeah
i was like you know nems he was like
yeah bing bong [ __ ] your life
and i was like that's crazy um so i had
to explain to my son i'm like no you
don't understand like this dude is like
a very elite level emcee
[Laughter]
do you run into that a lot now but we
was just in roscoe's and like two little
kids just came running up to me their
parents was like yo
sorry i don't want to bother you because
you take a picture i'm like man i love
it wow it's great man it's great i just
like
spent years
back in the days as a grimy individual
doing you know the wrong side of life
i've made you know produced a lot of
back home so it's good to just
be on the right side of things and
create wherever i walk in whether it's
hardcore rappers little kids old ladies
whoever it all when i walk in they all
get happy now you know what i'm saying
which is a great thing i love it yeah i
feel like uh
it's crazy because i feel like most
people might have like a moment like the
bing bong summer with the knicks and
sidewalk talk and all that
and like
not make the right moves to kind of
capitalize off that but i feel like
you've been on top of your [ __ ] bro
absolutely because you know what i've
been i've been grinding for years and
it's like i was
i always knew
if i stayed consistent and just kept on
and stayed true to myself something was
going to stick
so i've been putting in work
ready for this moment for years i didn't
know what it was going to be just so
happens to be the bing-bong [ __ ] but i
already had [ __ ] in order
don't don't ever disrespect me
was it afternoon yeah yeah bing bong
i started
march april of
before the actual next season started
yes yes so you were already doing the
bing bong shoot but it wasn't it was
actually kind of a freak
and then uh probably in like november
um it started taking off and
two months before that i had just
dropped an album with the song bing bong
right so it's perfect the song the bing
bong was just taking off right when they
started [ __ ] blowing up too at the
same time then i got the remix with fat
joe buster styles and it just was like
boom
that album did this thing i was doing
the numbers you know the videos
and then
to promote congo is when i started i was
like yo
i'm not on a major i'm doing you know
everything is paid for myself i gotta
you know my album's coming out in a week
what am i gonna do and i was like
just winning my hood yo i don't
disrespect my album coming out in three
days looking like that and then by the
time the album came out
people were like yo
we kind of don't want your album to come
out because we want to keep seeing these
videos so i was like i'm gonna keep
doing them and then just went into that
and also showed people like yeah i'm not
i could i make up flash [ __ ] all the
time you thought bing bong my [ __ ] was
gonna be over when that night right when
that was yeah don't ever disrespect me
taking over bro that [ __ ] don't ever
disrespect me [ __ ] it's like it's like
freestyle comedy at its best it's like
freestyling without having a rhyme
[Music]
[Laughter]
anybody ever like really get angry
um nah not really man because you know
why when i do it i'm not doing it like a
like a right like an [ __ ] like yo you
should [ __ ] don't ever dis now
i'm like yeah i don't disrespect a lot
of people don't even notice i'm doing it
to them and or they notice it after it's
already done like too late like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] don't ever disrespect
me looking like captain puerto rico
yo and i'm doing it with a smile and i'm
six four three fifty right you know what
i'm saying like
you know what's gonna really happen yeah
yeah and it's crazy too because like did
you notice like uh
because i want to give you another and i
might be wrong giving you credit for
this
but i feel like the new pause is ao yeah
absolutely right absolutely saucy
santana the gay rapper yeah yeah yeah
and i was talking to him about whether
or not paz was at home uh
homosexual pause um
homophobic yeah and he was like nah he's
like me and my homies do the same thing
but we'd be like hey yo yeah yeah
everybody that's your thing
it kind of
it's like a new york thing but i feel
like you made it pop at least yes but
see
everybody a lot of people in new york
say i'm not going to take credit for
creating it
but i feel like
you know um humbly that it did start
taking over the like you know instead of
pauses ao now because of the viral video
yeah and um but before that i always was
saying and the people around me from
like say philly or other places would
just start saying it as well when they
after they be around me you know what
i'm saying and like yeah you know they
didn't understand that was like poor so
they just start saying it on regular
[ __ ] like oh i spilled my shade yo you
know i'm sure yeah oh no you don't do it
like that you know what i'm saying yeah
no uh well listen man you've been on a
run and i think it's just dope because
like like you said you've been
consistently doing this [ __ ] for so long
and like to see it pay off is in one way
or the other it's like absolutely
incredible yeah yeah and you just told
me who was on this new album you got
coming with scram jones i don't know if
i could spill this spell it man listen
you said ghost face killers on you're
gonna hear it here first because i
haven't said it to anybody else um but
the rise of the silverback
nems fully produced by scramjones
it's coming out
end of november probably no end of
october early november so we got
ghostface
i forgot chic luch
angie martinez she may or may not be
rapping
um
fat joe
gunplay okay uncle murder
dave east
petey crack shout out to state property
yeah these are all people that i've
always throughout the years wanted to
work with me i don't care if they're
buzzing now or what like whatever
i [ __ ] with talented people and people
that i [ __ ] with like their music and i
feel like all these guys brought their
[ __ ] best like ghost face
he laid a verse on there that was just
like sounded like [ __ ] first wu-tang
album type [ __ ] ghostface is a he's
about my fifth favorite mc of all time
he's in my top five he's definitely my
top five as well yeah yeah most
consistent in in all of the of the
absolutely yeah supreme clientele is
probably my top three albums
on apollo kids yeah that's that's i have
a playlist
that you know i made playlists just so i
could have in the car of so there's one
playlist of songs that say
never gets old like [ __ ] that i never
get sick of apollo kids is on there
mighty healthy is on there almighty
deadly whatever the [ __ ] mighty healthy
yeah yeah um
yeah there's a lot of there's a couple
ghost face joints on there
when you like reach out to ghost facers
the other way around like oh hey yo
pause
[Laughter]
so ghostface i'm on his album 36 seasons
okay so i put two verses on there so
he's [ __ ] with you i always yeah i
always held that in my back pocket like
all right go sh you owe me a verse i'm
not gonna like press the issue but i
gave you two verses and i'm saying yeah
of course i got paid through the labels
and all that but um but then
ghosts didn't know me at that time that
was put together by i think like bob
perry or somebody else but with ghosts
probably why i haven't listened to yeah
when i see these random mutant albums
that look like the artist is not like
a hundred percent to be fair yeah but um
bob perry yeah i'm sure ghost had to
approve it of course yeah it's a bag
yeah yeah and it was an honor for me
because one song is just me a ghost the
other one is just me a cool g rap on a
ghost album ghost is not even on that
song that i'm on his album man cool g
rappers only well first of all that's
incredible that you are on a record with
called your rap second of all
g raps new album oh okay okay okay guy
you're on his new album yeah it's about
to come out oh wow so you're on two
songs with him so yeah it's full circle
you're on a ghostface song that
ghostface isn't on and you're on a cool
g rap yes
yeah um it's full circle you know why
because a lot of these people at the
time they may not this the 36th season
is from 2016. so nobody really he none
of the bigger artists knew about me but
through the years after i did that i
would see with ghost face he was showing
me a lot of love but then ghostface
you know i guess he started finding out
who i was and just really getting into
myself he was like your name is i got
you a hundred percent i just don't go to
the studio a lot but when i when i go
next time you top priority and when he
sent it i was like
well worth the wait
well worth the wait 100 it sounds like
vintage ghost face i was like yo he kind
of bodied me on my own [ __ ] that's a
good thing and that's okay you would
like that i'm not one of these i was
like yo yeah i tried to
body everybody that said yeah it's
called you know but when i'd rather have
a dope ass song than
a mediocre song where i'm bodying
somebody else on it i'm i'm all about
the the full product
yeah it's almost like you want if you're
gonna have ghost face on a song you want
to have the best ghost face possible
facts it's like if someone got a whole
verse and was like i kind of don't want
hope to overshadow i'm like no it's
jay-z exactly like everyone's talking
about this khalid jay-z versus well you
spent like a hundred balls on that
people forget rick ross and little
wayne's on and that's okay yes
absolutely jay-z spit 100 bars exactly
exactly
nah uh no that's crazy shout out to
ghost uh fat joel obviously hopped on
the bing bong remix um sheik looch also
a silverback gorilla yo that's why i put
him he's on the title track rise of the
silverback is featuring sheik luch um
sheik you know so he's with anybody the
gorillas he's the sylvia he's albums
called silverback you know what i'm
saying so i felt like it was a natural
thing and um
when that whole when we did the bing
bong remix
vinnie idol produced it and he's like a
d-block producer so originally i wanted
uh fat joe
busta and the whole lox on it
um
i feel like if we would have had more
time i would have got that
but uh styles
sent this [ __ ] mad quick and then you
know jada was doing [ __ ] i seen jada
recently he was like yo i owe you a
verse i got you 100
um he was like i was supposed to do the
remix but i didn't get to it but i got
you um and sheik
he had ready had given me uh that verse
a while ago you know so he you guys each
have high level like disrespectful
violence in your yeah yeah yeah like you
and cheek are very high high levels both
about this i know i'm fatter than him
but he's both
just like random like objects getting
stabbed
uh that's dope though man so hopefully
scramjones get it together man no no
it's done but it's late october okay
okay okay it's done
yeah yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] november yeah you
got later on
facts um andrew martinez rapping she
might be she might not be
but she's on the album we're gonna find
out yeah yeah you she took a lot you
guys did an interview so like she's the
best she's amazing she's a [ __ ]
legend man when i got that call like yo
angie once you're on the show i was like
wow really that's kind of like
validation like cause especially in new
york city if you're familiar with a lot
of like like
she only interviews like the top of the
top exactly what are you saying
i'm saying that what are you [ __ ]
saying i'm on the [ __ ] bottom bro
saying that like that validates what
you're doing because she don't just
interview everybody yeah nah 100 and she
was totally in tune with what i was
doing and uh i found out she's
fake from coney island from my
neighborhood what is it vaguely why
because if you look on a map
geographically the area she's from would
be considered coney island
but if you're from coney island it's not
coney island it's not coney island and
that's what she explained i was like yo
ann just i heard all through these years
you're from colonial she was like yo i'm
from beach haven and i was like oh yeah
she was like so you know that's not
really coney island but it is coney
island it's like a weird thing it's not
really the hood coney island which is
calling out so but she's you know so she
always showed me mad love and uh
yeah it's dope let me ask you this this
is random have you made it to detroit
since
you're not sent no but i've been to
detroit many times all this these years
okay i just yeah everyone's like you got
to go to oconee island while you're in
detroit yeah yeah and i was like isn't
that a place in brooklyn yeah so we went
to the coney islands in detroit
it's hot dogs yeah but it's so crazy
that it's like so embedded into the
culture of detroit
so around the early 2000s when i was
battling doing the fight club [ __ ] and
all that i was [ __ ] with d12 heavy
bizarre proof rest in peace so i was
going out there
uh
numerous times but the first time i went
out there i'm like it's everywhere it's
a cornea i'm like yo why all these
stores say coney island on them what the
[ __ ] is this
and then i would go and i would be like
oh these are hot dogs so nathan's
inc which is like a original place in
conan and coney island they invented
kind of like hot dogs that's where
that's there that's all i guess they
could
not be [ __ ] guzzling all these
[ __ ] blizzy gladiators
so i guess they couldn't they didn't
want to i guess whoever created these
stores or started doing the coney
islands didn't want to pay nathan's
defeat and was just like yo [ __ ] nathan
who's just going to call it coney island
yeah it's like embedded out there but it
was like you got to go to a coney island
every neighborhood has their own yeah
it's
crazy wild yeah and they use it as like
a noun yeah yeah they don't call it hot
dogs they call it like you gotta you
gotta go to the coney island go go find
you a good coney island i'm like and
then they got everything in there they
got hot dogs they got [ __ ] pancakes
yeah
what do you want yo what are you what
are you eating i'm eating a coney it's
just like yo what the [ __ ] it's embedded
heavily out there you're 100 it's pretty
crazy um
hey what up it's brulee kev we got to
stop the interview to tell you what our
good friends at my bookie football
season has started my favorite time of
the year because i love to gamble on
football it makes watching football so
much fun it's my like literally i just
love watching football and i love it
even more when i got money on the line
and no matter where you are right now
what state what country you can get in
on the action it's winning season go to
my bookie sign up for a new account
register and get that double deposit
bonus using the promo code bootleg now
let me tell you what that means that
means when you go to my bookie let's say
you make a 250 deposit using the promo
code bootleg you'll have 500
to gamble with that's right they're
gonna double your [ __ ] money right
now they got the prop builder you could
bet on uh whether or not i don't know
well matthew stafford throw for three
touchdowns will kylo murray rush for a
touchdown you can put all those on one
thing and secure the [ __ ] bag
all right get online with your boy let's
get this money together my bookie go
sign up with that promo code bootleg and
double your deposit right now go
register how dope was it when because uh
was it
the white house or joe biden's page or
somebody that actually did the whole
[ __ ] iron hell yeah byron byron yeah
he renamed the president um it was him
well he didn't really say anything from
the thing he kind of it was the jonas
brothers right in the white house
and
at the end of the video you're just like
yo we got it it's him with the phone so
you know he was it was kind of his video
too right but uh i remember what i was
doing i think that might have been the
last day i ever packaged my own merch
because that's when it really was
blowing up but every day something was
happening with the bing bong [ __ ]
everybody every day somebody knew was
saying it well this day was [ __ ]
little nas x this day is john legend
singing hey yo
which i still got a sample by the way um
and every day was something new and new
and new and at that time the merch is
going crazy you know um so i'm packaging
my own [ __ ] i gotta hope my whole house
is full of mercy i gotta ship out i'm
like this is getting too crazy and i
remember shipping i had my man vanguard
with me helping me out and um
so my dm's like i stopped for a minute i
opened up my graham somebody did i'm
like oh
we made it like nah this is crazy the
president just said it crazy and uh
i mean you can't get more viral than
that what's um
like the latest on what's going on with
the joe byron guy
like the other he's out here in
california
i think he's in like coachella valley
where's palm springs yeah it's like it's
like coachella that's near there so
that's where he is somebody sent me a
video
of getting his [ __ ] together no doing
the same thing he was doing in [ __ ]
coney island but but [ __ ] i guess he
made it across country he's originally
from california oh so he just made it
back to yeah this is this i was looking
through my videos on instagram if you go
back i don't know all my lives not in my
regular [ __ ] i didn't post it on my like
the grid but there was one night i was
out calling and i just talked about like
yo what how the [ __ ] you want who are
you why'd you end up here i got his
whole story and he's originally from
california and he made it out there i
don't know his mother said you never
make it to new york some i don't know
what the [ __ ] it's all on my [ __ ] if you
just you got to search though but uh
he's somebody sent me a video like yo
i'm the byron guy like two kids were
like yo names look we got this guy out
here i was like oh that's where he is
because i haven't seen him was it wasn't
there like a um
was it like a gofundme he made more
money off that video than any of us he
made like 40 racks off of that good for
him
absolutely i don't think he has any more
of it i think he spent it all
and he's back to square one at least
he's back in california at least he got
out here with exactly at the very least
he's back home yeah yo we reunited him
with his son when the videos came out
his son dm me like yo that's my father
[ __ ] and i i asked him i was like yo you
got a son
he's like little tj he started [ __ ]
crying i was like yo look
he's just dm me he was like
so did he grasp how popping like that
video game oh yeah yeah because once
after a while we would be like yo
where's this guy we emcee him for a
minute he would just yeah he would just
pop up in times square and just be like
just yell out byron then crowds would
form around him
he was loving it he probably still loves
it remember that one dude uh
they got him got him
yeah yeah that dude is is obviously he
had him i seen him get scared on the
train somebody bullied him or some [ __ ]
no bro he's like
if you're if you go to vegas or i've
seen him on hollywood boulevard just
like he's like down bad bro like he's
i'm pretty sure he's homeless or close
to it that's i've seen a video recently
yeah he's not doing something i've seen
him like in person on hollywood
boulevard i was like
that's melting
he already looked like something
beforehand
but
like he um
there was a video he was on like a train
station and somebody was like yo
he was like he looks scared to death
like yo please don't hurt me the guy was
like yo i'm not trying to hurt you bro i
just want you to say it and he was like
oh okay got him yeah got him
[Laughter]
that's gotta be terrible
uh but you've been doing like it's cool
because i you were doing some i saw you
do some comedy night [ __ ] right yeah
demo i thought my own comedy show so
um i'm trying to touch money in every
[ __ ] area you're all so hilarious
like you're like a special but it's like
you're my kind of like bro the first
time we met and you rapped on on my show
and just yeah
yeah yeah but i was like
i love
that level of like just your bars just
was like so [ __ ]
crazy i was like me and this guy are the
same kind of guy
absolutely but it's it's it's a dif it's
like
if somebody gives me a microphone it's
like yo go in front of that crowd and be
[ __ ] hilarious i probably won't be
but if i'm just normally on the street
with just joking i feel like you can do
crowd work yeah i just have to put in
the work i know i mean like because you
know there's like comedians who have
like a 10 minute set oh yeah people that
just [ __ ] with the crowd but then
there's like guys who are really good
like andrew scholes is like yeah he's an
amazing regular comedian but he's also
great at just if there's a couple in the
front row that look crazy nah i didn't
know i went to a show the infamous he
gave me tickets i got i'm cool with him
now i was like yeah you were on this
show right
now no i did like uh i saw him talking
about it yeah yeah he talked about it on
the show i also linked up with him i did
uh he did a video to promote his
concerts that were going on so after i
did that he gave me the tickets to radio
city and i actually watched his show the
guy's [ __ ] hilarious and he was and i
know that's when i started seeing how he
was [ __ ] with the crowd and then the
other day i was with russell peters like
i saw that i'm here right yeah a lot of
these comedians like [ __ ] with me and
wrestle peter's a [ __ ] hip hop head i
didn't know that hardcore russell
peter's a [ __ ] real one [ __ ] with
that he was dj in it yeah yeah he was
using before he was a comedian he told
like we but he invited me he's like yo
you're in l.a come [ __ ] with me i went
to his house just thinking i was gonna
say what up bro me my whole crew
stayed there probably the whole night to
like from like four afternoon to like
two in the morning it's amazing and and
just had a great time dwayne martin from
above the rim
well well chillin it's like surreal
these are all people you know above the
rim you grow up a girl watching that um
track
we talked about that yeah we talked
about that the grit and that soundtracks
what other soul in the hole was that the
one where
his brother died and he was like i
didn't even see the movie i still
noticed is it that one
soul in the hole
wasn't dwayne martin in another
basketball movie where he's a basketball
player
he spoke about that he said oh he's in
white men can't jump he's a white man
can't jump okay yeah
there was a wayans brother in a movie
where one of the two guys died and his
br it wasn't dwayne martin then do you
know what you know what movie i'm
talking about
like it was like two guys were on a team
they might have been brothers or they
were best friends or something and one
of the two guys died and then the rest
of the season like
the guy's ghost is like helping him play
like crazy but it's like a comedian yeah
it's like a comedy i don't remember it
wasn't a good movie
but you know what other soundtracks are
[ __ ] great what's your top five
soundtracks honestly i just think i
really think eight miles is the best one
ever really yeah that's it's a dope
soundtrack i think that was the last of
the good soundtracks i think eight mile
had the best eminem ever
and to me if you have three records on
there that are the best eminem that
exists
yeah and he's one of the greatest of all
time
yeah absolutely and then there was this
century the best
you get you better love me [ __ ] yeah 50
obi won eminem was on that too that's
foreign
one
eight miles and running wasn't that jay
and free i know they were you know that
wang still was on there yeah you're
right that's a fire soundtrack
nutty professor was a fire soundtrack
nutty professor had the eminem red man
yeah
yeah and it had [ __ ] uh
foxy [ __ ] yeah it had mashed it that
nutty nutty professor was crazy
above the rim was a fire one was great
colors was crazy um
friday
friday friday's number two for me
booyah gunshots
the uh the keep the head ringing keep
that yeah the doctor dr drake keep your
hand oh you know which one was hard was
bullworth
yes
i liked um i wasn't mad at the 50 cent
uh movie for soundtrack
the movie was terrible but
you didn't like that i mean i didn't
love it i feel like it was uh i didn't
it's kind of was like the same thing as
eminem's
right just like this i didn't love a
mile so you know i like i think it was
cool no i think i was fine shout out to
brittany murphy yeah no no the battle
scenes are amazing yeah that's just
crazy okay i have a belly poster behind
you and i always say that belly that's a
fire sound crazy that's one that might
be number one the gang star militia
remix with dub c's on there that
uh uh here comes the boom here comes
yeah yeah you might be right it's up
there half a mil mm-hmm
there was some [ __ ] on this um they had
the locks with made men that brown not
no devil in there
and a dress or something d'angelo's pie
yeah they had the nas
uh
method man and dmx joint great
soundtrack yeah that's why it sounds is
it the best worst movie of all time
you think belly's a bad movie i think
it's a great bad movie yeah yeah i could
agree on that because growing up i just
thought it was a great movie yeah and
then once i started watching like a lot
of movies yeah
and then i tried to re-watch belly like
again like at like 24 25 i was like
you know wasn't as good as i remember it
was just a great like looking movie and
it had my favorite rappers in it exactly
so it was [ __ ] amazing there was like
moments like in the beginning where they
go into the [ __ ] bathroom before the
guns out shoot up the lady in the club
and then [ __ ] uh with dmx is [ __ ]
dressed like a homeless guy yeah yeah it
has nothing to do with nothing is this
random acts of violence the dude's
eating the [ __ ] the the fruit glizzy
the banana and he's like oh yeah yeah we
gotta drop the guy i don't like this
[ __ ]
that's like going on uh uh uh like a
great like a six flags when you're a kid
like yo this place is huge and then you
go there as an adult and like it's not
that big over here what i'm saying it's
just kind of small got like [ __ ] four
rods yeah well you guys have a roller
coaster and uh
it's like famous is
yeah that should break your [ __ ] back
those wouldn't i should i don't ride
that [ __ ] no more the last time i got
that i had like whiplash bro that [ __ ]
hurts he said whiplash [ __ ] that
appreciate y'all watching but listen our
partners at blue chew they got you
handled fellas and etc whatever you are
they got it if you got a dick blue chew
is for you because they will make sure
your dick performs at all time levels i
mean like lebron his first three seasons
with the heat type levels i mean your
wife will thank you for it everybody
will thank you for it [ __ ] even if you
just take a blue chew and jerk your dick
it's a it's a stronger jerk i swear to
god stronger [ __ ] jerk for sure you're
gonna be beating your dick like i stole
something
so what you got to do is go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg right now and
you're going to get your first month
free and this is the great thing about
bluechu the same active ingredients as
viagra and as cialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at blue chew use the promo code
bootleg and you're getting your first
month delivered to your door
in discreet packaging i'm telling you
you're going to think me later all right
if you've gotten bluetooth already just
dm me tell me just
just dm me no photos just tell me how
you know let me just tell you it's
[ __ ] amazing our producer cyrus's
daddy 70 took the blue chew he's [ __ ]
just beating down all the senior citizen
[ __ ] available in arizona right now so
go to bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg or just hit the link in the
description of this video let's get back
to the interview um i saw you you
obviously been doing the dru league [ __ ]
a lot the crew leagues the crew yeah
yeah yeah hosted the last two seasons my
last the last season that came out in
the new season that's about to come out
great great had a great time yeah i shot
to eli my god because was it was it you
and uh was drewski doing stuff no
drewski did the first two seasons okay
okay okay and then you were after yeah
he did season one and two and i did
season three and four any like uh
interesting uh times during during the
cause
who's who of everybody's playing no you
wound up getting cool with with with
guys that i would never expect i got
cool with uh
24k golden no i would never expect me to
get caught
great great guy great guys [ __ ] with him
heavy oh
i got cool with wacko
rock is great
block is the man um also a lot better of
a rapper than people know
he's he actually really good he just
dumbs himself down really for sure
that's really what it is like um
yeah i just make a lot of connections
with solid individuals you know what i'm
starting to learn as i get to meet a lot
more people in this industry it's the
people that
the the the public and i'm not saying
the people i mentioned um
about them but a lot of people that i
meet that people be like ah nah this
guy's corny or this guy is this or that
wind up being the coolest ones right the
people that think are like cool as [ __ ]
and wound up being [ __ ] weirdos and
[ __ ]
you know kind of corny and just like
it's always the ones that people just
like don't really give credit to that
wanna be like yo this guy's a [ __ ]
solid individual man who who was that so
i was like yo you're you're a [ __ ]
great guy uh
[ __ ] trinidad james oh yeah
but i think i was biased because he had
that [ __ ] going on with new york where
he said like whatever he said about new
york at that time remember i remember
yeah so i spoke to him about that but
after you know because he did the crew
league just right now we did in atlanta
and i spent the whole weekend with him
and i'm like at the end of the week i'm
like oh man you're a [ __ ] good great
guy you're a solid individual bro yeah i
think like
it's so weird because i almost feel like
he was like kind of like his success
was like almost what bit him in the ass
and then i think that new york thing
kind of like
it really hindered him i think yeah
absolutely but yo he's in new york all
the time he does the complex
his show the sneaker shows yeah
uh full-size run
i just think when you have like a record
like old gold everything and it's your
first [ __ ] song
and it's just so [ __ ] big and it's so
[ __ ] ignorant and like people ain't
seen [ __ ] like that before yeah and then
you're kind of beeping with new york
yeah yeah it's like
it's like a lot of people were probably
like hoping that he was like a flash in
the panel yeah and i think like
artistically he actually has some some
other dope [ __ ] yeah absolutely but his
his uh his shows though i catch it on
you like it depends on who he has on
yeah yeah it's like him in like two
random might do that yeah yeah i was on
it yeah i had a great time on that i
think i saw you one yeah
i was trying to stay pretty tapped in
with your run i saw you on chrissy d's
podcast yo was that does he do that at
his house yes i had no idea who he was
beforehand
i don't like doing a lot of podcasts
because i feel like it's all the same
[ __ ] questions over and over and over
uh so a lot of times i say no
now he hit me up
dm me yo what's up man big fan
bing bong just pout you're a big fan
everyone's a big yeah everybody's a big
fan yo you wanna come on my podcast i'm
like nah not really
and he asked me again like a couple days
later
i was like
where is he he was like i said in the
car for you everything like that i
wanted to be in like 20 minutes from my
house 15 minutes i was like all right
bro i'll come
i went there but i had a great time bro
yeah it was a dope episode he's he's
great yeah and then i realized
this guy is really popping
and his kids are kind of like you yeah
in terms of the mixture of
[Music]
he's a great guy he's [ __ ] a great
comedian i had no idea all this i tapped
in afterwards and uh i'm like oh you
know that [ __ ] was dope
yeah yeah i think i think i i can see
you getting it you got to get into that
i mean you're already doing it you're
doing a great job of like kind of
being a rapper and being just a great
entertainer yeah you know i'm trying to
juggle both because rap it's like the
entertainer [ __ ] is what's kind of
popping for me right now it's the bread
and butter but i'm at the core i'm a
[ __ ] rapper bro yeah i've been
[ __ ] doing this for years i come from
the battle [ __ ] i really come from that
there's also you're like first love
absolutely yeah it's what i always
envisioned my life being um and then
this other [ __ ] comes along that's more
lucrative and more popping right now and
this is like
all right it's pulling me away but
i'll always rap um movies absolutely i'm
i'm i'm
just a voiceover for hbo max that's not
really acting but i'm that's something
that's like one or two movies and i'm
starting we're shooting one when october
september we're shooting
yeah yeah not like belly tooth during
the game
you ever watch billy too no nobody i see
the comment transfers like you already
know this is going to be some [ __ ]
all the yeah
some of them old school like
movies where they would just put a
rapper on the [ __ ] poster
there was a naz movie he was in called
tick tock and he was in like for maybe
30 seconds but he was right on the
[ __ ] and i sure did rent that
[ __ ] just to watch nas die right
away
fat joe was in a lot of those movies
yeah yeah
he had a movie called uh remember who's
the man who's in who's the man [ __ ]
ed lover and dr dre but the east coast
doctor
yeah they had mad new york rappers like
everything i think it was a little i
probably was a little young for who's
the man but i do remember like uh
i mean obviously everybody remembers
like [ __ ] kill the season and i was
selling that [ __ ] at the swap meet but
before that like master p i got the hook
up yeah yeah yeah it was playing that on
like [ __ ] one of the shits the other
day i watched the little of it i was
like this [ __ ] is horrible exhibit and
busta rhymes co-starred in a terrible
movie together that i had on vhs
i've seen both of them last night yeah
of course you did at that show yeah
great
is the man bro oh he's the best axe is
the man as well i was hanging out with
busta rhymes uh he was playing a he had
a little intimate little extension level
event to uh
listening thing and he was just so cool
man
i was like because i like ran into him
in other places and tried to like had i
had people that know him like you know
introducing yeah and he seemed like
he kind of seemed like a dick of course
i mean listen when you're in the game
30 years bro you've seen it all done and
all i kind of feel like there's some
days where you're just like no i get it
bothered with this [ __ ] just make sure
nobody talks to me i don't want to take
[ __ ] pictures and and i i could see
now with those
you know it takes a lot of energy even
now mental mental energy yeah no that's
the most it takes everybody wants what
they want they don't give a [ __ ] if
you're having a bad day like yo let me
get a picture man bing bong yeah that
gives no [ __ ] yeah it's kind of it gets
you mental and i can see how uh
i'm i consider myself strong-minded i
could see how somebody that already
would have like
issues
could fold you know what i'm saying
because it does get there's there's
times when i'm out places and and i'm
not i'm not eminem i'm not drake you
know i could see what the they can't
even go outside but i see
there's times where like i want to leave
and i'm stuck
i need this picture picture picture like
i can't go this way that way this way
whatever and it's like all right this is
what i always wanted so this is what you
wanted this is what i wanted it's cold
and you're go you got to be glad that it
happened to you now absolutely and now
when you had like drug problems you were
like really i always always feel like
recently i've been thinking about that a
lot like for years i was like yo damn i
was i had
i had opportunities with shady i had
opportunities with def jam why didn't
that happen now for years i was
questioning myself why didn't that
happen
it's clear to me now it's like i wanna
[ __ ] kill myself you weren't right or
killed somebody you know what i'm saying
like
it would have it would have ended badly
whatever whatever way it would have went
it would have ended badly and uh you
know that just
shows that everything happens for a
reason it don't happen when you wanted
to it happens when it's supposed to
whatever the reason whatever the reason
is
you know [ __ ] is not gonna happen on
your time it happens on
god's time or the universe's time
whatever you choose to call it and uh
you know
i'm just happy that i'm i'm and lucky
that i'm blessed i got a mother who
prays for me every day i have good
family and people around me that make
sure i feel like you're always at the
same squat around you yeah is it pretty
easy for you to like because i know you
had some sort of struggles we talked
about the last time you hear what it was
sobriety and [ __ ] but now that you're
popping there's more money there's more
cool [ __ ] going on around you has it
been like have you been pretty have you
ever been tempted to like get back into
some [ __ ] [ __ ] or [ __ ] always been
around me like like alcohol
weed that [ __ ] is always around me you
know what i'm saying i'm not one of
those people that don't do any that
don't do drugs or drink that be like nah
you can't do that around me i'm not a
party please do what you got to do
that's it i know what's good i know
what's good for me what works for me and
i know that if
i take a drink i'm somebody that can't
do one of anything bro i can't do one
blunt one drink
[ __ ] one dollar one woman
i'm saying like like i always gotta do
things in [ __ ] exercises
so
i already know there's no myth there i
know that if you if i choose to take a
drink i'm gonna drink until i get drunk
and throw up if i smoke i'm gonna smoke
blunts all [ __ ] day if i pop a pill
i'm gonna pop non-stop and so i'm
[ __ ] passed out you know what i'm
saying yeah if i [ __ ] sniff if i
sniff some coke bro i'm gonna [ __ ] go
on a month-long run and nobody's gonna
see me you know what i'm saying have you
ever been on a month-long coke run yeah
not coke rum but just a month long just
drunk
life
drug of garbage head you know i did
everything i mean i didn't smoke crack
like we talked about
needles but i did everything bro and not
you know i was on a [ __ ] eight year
run how about that
now i've had family members that we just
like we just wouldn't see for like two
months yeah well that's how it gets my
like my aunt would just drop off her
kids with my grandparents
and just see you
well that's how it gets
and it's not even necessarily because
that's what you plan to happen or you
want to happen it's just what what
happens you know what i'm saying it's
not because
you know if you listen if you've got
somebody in your life that's doing drugs
or addicted and you feel like they're
doing it to you personally don't take it
like that it's not like i could tell you
from experience like i never wanted to
[ __ ] family members over or [ __ ] friends
over it's just you know we're not doing
that purposely it's just
it's kind of what happens that's what
happens man yeah now i've had
you know my cousin steal [ __ ] from me
and i mean
yeah it's just almost like uh
you know it's not the real them i guess
yeah
that's real though it's hard not to take
it personal after off club no big time
lee crazy of course i'm gonna take that
[ __ ] matt personal now that i'm on the
other side yeah take that [ __ ] mad
person i don't give a [ __ ] what you got
going [ __ ] your life but i'm just
[ __ ] fought five crackheads right
outside the gate he's my first smoking
fat no right like right here on the side
that's crazy brothers they were i feel
like [ __ ] now in la i was
probably everywhere
they got that fentanyl
you know we talk about like [ __ ] being
spiked with fentanyl no [ __ ]
that's what they want yeah they're like
no i need the no give me the fetty wire
i spoke to
a homeless person he was a fiend and he
said something about fed like yeah i
knew i knew i was i smoked fat i said
smoke i thought that [ __ ] kills you when
you do it he was like nah we put in the
tin foil and smoke it now and that [ __ ]
gets you man high [ __ ] up i'm like yo
until you actually go out and look for
fat no no you're not looking for crack
you're not looking for purges you're
just looking for fentanyl death it's
insane
that's just playing with your life it's
crazy yeah
we got to stop the interview tell you
about our partners at odd socks well
first of all let's check out the brand
new collab
look at these the bootleg kev sock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
gonna figure out a way to give them away
though uh but look odd socks the most
comfortable socks in the world um and
the best thing about odd socks is
they're our family man i've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and i will not wear anything else on my
feet like i swear to god i'm about to
take my shoe off i'm about to take the
look what is this
it smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's awesome basic you
know what i'm saying we [ __ ] with odd
socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about nickelodeon
shout out to patrick [ __ ]
cheez-its baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little pop-tart underwear yeah i
mean yeah these are the odd socks basics
all right so if you go to the website
right now order you some underwear order
you some socks use the promo code
bootleg kev that's one word all together
bootleg kev and you will save 20 off at
checkout go to
oddssocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddssoxoficial.com promo code
bootleg kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course we're presented by
odd socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview so
uh since uh the joe byron thing has
popped up are you vote can you vote
first of all i don't know you know have
you ever voted i voted one time for
obama
won like the first run yeah when he
first uh won i don't know if it counted
cuz i'm a felon um but my felony is over
10 years old i feel like and i i believe
at some point i got it expunged like you
know like after 10 years you could get
the [ __ ] exposure so i think i went
through that process um
so i don't know i don't really vote that
much i feel like either side is lying to
you both sides are full of [ __ ] yeah
facts and we're [ __ ] either way you're
[ __ ] either way
one side you got this divisive
psychopath who is [ __ ]
nervous
and then on the other side you got this
dude who's about to die
[Music]
it's like what the [ __ ] is happening can
we can the rock run for president please
somebody
somebody the rednecks and the regular
people together crazy i feel like it's
got to be a pro wrestler it's got me to
rock
everyone loves pro wrestling everyone
loves the rock the most racist people in
the world
as an adult i do yeah yeah i do i
haven't watched that [ __ ] since i was
good yeah me and my kid watch it
still my [ __ ] okay you know it is what
it is man who who hit me what wrestler
just hit me who's the queen of the ring
the queen of the ring she was the first
queen of the ring oh
she she invited me like when the big
ball happened she's like yo come to the
balcony you would be a sick ass manager
you know like bobby the brain here yeah
just you would be like the mountains
yeah
yo yeah
you'd be like the paul heyman of the rap
game get into that
max aew
that's next that's next man you got to
figure that out dude who's the girl like
if i tell you her name you'll be like oh
yeah yeah she's [ __ ] popping because
i did that's
she's she was decree she won queen of
the ring she's wrestling now yeah
i don't know was it eight she was a wwe
my son would know yeah
so
she hit me up like yo next one come out
like i really don't
you care about right i don't really
watch wrestling you go in person you'll
be like this shit's crazy i used to go
all the time when i was a kid yeah the
bushwackers did that [ __ ] to me like
yeah yeah hell yeah when i was a kid
hell yeah i met the bushwhackers
i lived in tampa and they had a a gym
that they were part owners of above hulk
hogan's
beach shop in clearwater beach and
yeah they were not how i remembered they
were just very elderly
and orange something about that florida
orange
white people just turn orange in florida
man
you see hulk hogan orange donald trumpy
and mar-a-lago orange as [ __ ] my focus
is orange in florida man uh so you got
the album coming in november no
some movies coming yup voice over for
hbo max comedy shows i'm trying to do
that [ __ ] monthly the comedy show thing
i feel like you could like low-key like
just do a tour low-key i want i mean
like a straight i mean obviously you're
doing the music thing on tour you're
doing clubs and [ __ ] i mean like you
could probably i want to do like a
gorilla weekend in every city like one
like a three-day week and friday
saturday sunday night when's the rap
show when's the comedy show and the
other day's a pop-up shot with the merch
oh
what's your biggest market outside of
new york um
can you tell these kind of things like
yeah hell yeah i haven't looked into it
recently um but i know
but that [ __ ] really ships everywhere i
shipped this [ __ ]
japan australia even though australia
cut off shipping for the recovery
they cut off everything during this yeah
freedom [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] that um
canada i get a lot of toronto
cali a lot all over california not just
la like the whole cali all over big time
who's been the most random
like celebrity outside of the president
that has like tapped in with you and
like been like
shaq shaquille o'neal and he and he dm
me and this is right when the bing bong
happened and he uh he was like yo that
bing bong [ __ ] is fire he was like
forget the catchphrase the song mm-hmm
and i was like i tried to catch him i
was like yo shaq i know you got bars bro
i'm gonna send you the beat
let's do it let's do a rem he sent me a
video reply in the dm i think i posted
that i don't post dm but i was like yo
this is he was like shaq he was like yo
he was like
i ain't [ __ ] with you right now he's
like yo you like the michael jordan this
rap [ __ ] man i'm over here being
corporate he was shooting the commercial
i was like yo shaq calling me the
michael jordan the rap is crazy and he
was like yeah i can't [ __ ] with you
right now i'm trying to get this
corporate money he's the best uh
basketball rapper ever i think
i'm i haven't heard dame
well you know what i forget about dame
damon is pretty pretty i haven't heard i
heard him like no dame's solid is he
yeah he's solid
shot but shaq was like he has joints
with the rizzo
[ __ ] that shaq got a song with jay-z and
nas at the same time
now they weren't
because everybody always used to talk
about during the jay-z nozbeef that they
never worked together but no no no i
forgot about them they were on a
shaquille o'neal song
i doubt that's like mike geronimo he got
jay-z dmx and um
john rule on this on his like album back
in the days was mike geronimo a part of
that cipher video
with big pun yeah and most def yeah
moe's
cannabis
was my turn on him he was there right
mike jerome was there and what's his
name from the food jesus he was that was
good
john forte john forte who caught a crazy
fed case and then got pardoned he got
pardoned by who pardoned him
yeah he's a [ __ ] jew he was crazy
about john 14 i think he had liquid
cocaine on him at the airport i don't
even think it was normal he's tapped
then we got him a [ __ ] pardon from
bush not even obama or trump which would
be i could see obama because you know
obama's pretty you know
trump is just like yo
who's paying himself that's how i
figured it he got kodak out i was hoping
that he would have got uh the the tiger
king [ __ ] guy out yeah
he was like nah this guy's like me i
ain't [ __ ] with this guy yeah he got
the fact part in kodak black is crazy
and a little wing and wayne
the kodak black [ __ ] was special
you like as an old head right because
i'm an old head i mean i'm not saying
you're old yeah but
we are very similar yeah music
are you able to enjoy like uh some of
the young [ __ ] like yeah maybe a young
boy should yeah kodak i love kodak yeah
me too i like this [ __ ] um yeah i listen
all that i listen to drill [ __ ] cuz i'm
from you know new york the drill [ __ ] i
can say i can handle some of the drill
[ __ ]
same
to me i'm like i don't tap in with who
they beefing with i don't give a [ __ ]
about that yeah yeah i don't pay
attention to none of that it's so much
of that [ __ ] um but it's like his own
version of l.a yeah yeah yeah the drill
politics or the absolutely so right now
in new york on the radio and the clubs
and the strip clubs
the drill [ __ ] yeah taking over it's
like completely so it's kind of like
impossible to not [ __ ] with it because
when a girl is shaking her ass in front
of you and she loves the song and the
eyes are shaking better when
you start liking the [ __ ] song you
know what i'm saying you know i [ __ ]
with like i went out there and i think i
had hit you um
when i was in new york this was before
the big bunk ship when i was out there i
was uh shooting in canarsie with um
dusty locain and
a bunch of them dudes and that's when i
really got educated to all the beef yeah
yeah that's all they do is beef i'll
deal with that [ __ ] jesus that's crazy i
was like dived into a youtube wormhole
oh you could
it's [ __ ] yeah
between like the drill beef [ __ ] the
brooklyn and the bronx [ __ ] and then
jacksonville there's like youtube
wormholes galore where you could be like
what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah it's crazy it's like i didn't like
i was like talking to like one of these
guys i was like yeah i was like yeah i
was listening to uh 22 g's guys he's
hard and i didn't realize that like
there's like death involved in like
these two guys and
and uh
they had to stop me and be like yo yo
don't
just so you know that's the hops or
whatever i'm like [ __ ] yeah it's crazy
it's like something else yeah that's
what happens when i come out here my guy
over there he'll be telling me oh this
is not this overheadless so yeah i don't
be knowing either yeah but the music is
cool some of it's cool some of it's
saying yeah this is what's just like
everything else looks like everything
else absolutely yeah i like you know
what i'm [ __ ] with i'm [ __ ] with
the uk [ __ ]
the grime the drill [ __ ] the uh yeah
before the drill was the grime [ __ ] the
grime [ __ ] was like i like that grime
[ __ ] though grimes i don't know if it's
still popping there's that central sea
guy who's got the funniest [ __ ] song
i never heard it was like how can i be
homophobic my [ __ ] is gay
i didn't hear that i've never heard
you've never heard the song oh it's the
[ __ ] it's my [ __ ] oh i heard it
he's like uh hugging my brother's tell
him i love him though i don't swing that
way
yeah somebody told your cat that's just
hard
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] man anything else
you got going on man nah [ __ ] your life
[ __ ] your life yeah it was it was super
dope to see fat joe kind of call you the
new fat joe crazy yeah crazy fat joe as
well people don't know one of the most
highly disrespectful just
authentic yeah
crazy people in hip-hop back in the day
absolutely they see him now and no no
he's sweetheart great guys
i remember reading like a list of like
his alleged incidents on complex and
like oh wait i'm like
obviously all the legends yeah yeah yeah
this guy had it out with uh what i'm
trying to remember the boxer
he he's told the story before what which
boxer oh right uh roy jones roy jones
they had like a thing at a nightclub
yeah because he said to lean back even
roy jones was lost to lean back he was
hmm
yeah well listen man i appreciate you
pulling up we're gonna have you do
another freestyle cause we got some
crazy ones together absolutely we're
gonna run it back yeah gorilla names
[ __ ] your life go buy some merch fyl dot
nyc the merch is crazy absolutely it's
always crazy high level [ __ ] i don't
know who this lady who's that ivory man
the bum on my block
oh [ __ ] lovable homeless woman that we
all love she made mad money off these
shirts shout out to ivory there it is
everybody eats